The invasion of the apostrophes has begun.
At precisely sometime this morning, the two words, "it" and "is"...
...were part of an apostrophe incident.
One of the letters was removed.
The letter "i" was replaced by the apostrophe, making a new shorter word "it's."
At exactly sometime in the afternoon, two more words, "I" and "have,"...
...were approached by an apostrophe.
This time, two letters were removed!
The remaining letters huddle together, unaware that an apostrophe...
...has replaced the letters that were between them.
The apostrophe caused the two words to contract into a single, shorter word.
For their own protection, we have protected these words at this facility.
Does not.
Wait!
What's this?
Those fiendish apostrophes; they've taken the "o"!
Doesn't.
Is no word safe?
Watch the skies!
They're everywhere.
It's the invasion of the apostrophes!